what was so urgent that you had to rush
to start city aliens have you lost your
mind I'm not gonna call you Supergirl
stupid did you get the name Pete wait I
like to light things on fire
none of us and me lifelong mere tools
versus aliens the four night crossover
event starts with Supergirl this Monday
at 8:00 7:00 central on the CW
heetu Burgesses charlie so new crossover
footage let's break it down
there's also another viral trailer that
I'll explain later in the video but it's
a little weird so I'm gonna do this
first I love this trailer just a little
bit better just because of that heatwave
supergirl moment I'm not calling you
Supergirl cuz that's stupid
why do they call you heatwave because I
like the light stuff on fire and
Supergirl just like oh okay
and then he torches the Dominator and
what would be their nuts if they did
have nuts but the thing is is that she
also has heat vision
maybe they'll bond over that or maybe
she'll just like bring him a beer or
something like that I feel like it's
actually pretty easy to get in good with
heatwave as long as you know what speed
he moves that just bring him a beer
don't try to talk to him and leave him
alone but they have a little bit of
footage from each of the different
episodes in this so like when Barry
comes to Star City and Felicity's like
what what are you doing here Barry
and he just tries to explain aliens to
them you see some more of this warehouse
footage that look like they're getting
rid of throw down there's obviously
gonna be a bunch of big action
set-pieces like you know big fight
scenes and big open spaces shot of their
ship Oliver on their ship firing one of
their weapons maybe this is part of that
arrow episode there's a big twist so I'm
curious to see how they explained him in
like that false reality the group shot
this is kind of like that arrow scene
from earlier this year where they did
the cool guy explosion where Oliver
walks away without looking at it this is
like the version of that on steroids
more open battle looks like they blow up
the flash mobile there will be revenge
how dare you blow up the flash mobile it
almost looks like vixen citizens steel
and heatwave are stuck in a prison
somewhere but this just might be a
meeting like the way they cut it and
then them outside assembled at this
airport tarmac makes me think that they
might do a version of like the Captain
America Civil War Airport battle scene
one of the reasons they picked that and
civil war to do the huge battle scene is
because it was really easy from a
filmmaking standpoint because you have
all these characters so it's just like
really hard for them to all move around
and for you to be able to see them in
really cool ways you couldn't really do
that in a small contained space so
naturally like it's even harder to film
an episode of TV because they have to
move so much quicker so it would make
sense that they would have like a big
huge scene in a big open space so
airports Airport hangars like we've seen
in the
other trailers is just an easy way to do
that and what about the Hall of Justice
posters that they've been releasing so
the comic book fold out style they've
been releasing one sheets for each of
the shows but when you stack them
together they all show the Hall of
Justice in the background Super Friends
unite so this might mean we'll get a
teaser for that somewhere in the
episodes but I'm not expecting to
actually see full-blown Hall of Justice
in like the real world I think in the
way they're teasing this future flash
storyline on legends they'll just like
wink at it like oh this is probably
going to be happening in the future of
these characters lives whether or not we
actually see it on the show remains to
be seen but never say never because like
we saw the flash Museum when Barry was
running back to save his mother at the
end of flash season one so you never
know so be prepared for Hall of Justice
that'd be pretty crazy if they actually
did it
so just to explain the schedule next
week Supergirl is mostly gonna be like a
Supergirl episode like a self-contained
story with like the N part dedicated to
this four night crossover so I will be
doing videos for like each of the
episodes for the four night crossover so
I might tune the Supergirl video just a
little bit because there'll be like a
lot of stuff that has absolutely nothing
to do with the four night crossover
flash will be like the first official
night like the whole episode will be
dedicated to the crossover on Tuesday
then arrow same thing on Wednesday then
legends of tomorrow same thing on
Thursday so all four episodes airing
next week
there's no episode of arrow tonight and
there's no legends of tomorrow but they
did just drop like another found-footage
trailer for legends for the four night
crossover so it's like a little bit
different but I'll play it here then
explain what's going on
[Applause]
[Music]
so they just meant to be a fun wink that
the dominators have tried to conquer
earth before the US Marine Corps went up
against them so that there's this
classified real it might be some area 51
twist on it
where it was like this big thing but
because it was so crazy and aliens the
government buried it never told anyone
about it but it's just a way to explain
that this isn't the first time that the
dominators have come to earth so at some
point in the four night crossover
they'll learn about that and learn how
they got rid of him the first time but
it should be a lot of fun like we just
had that flash episode that was super
crazy so I'm wondering how much of that
they're going to be addressing in
episode 8 next week I'm guessing that
like the four night crossover story is
gonna be relatively self-contained but
there are like a few things that will
bleed into the rest of the season on
each of the shows like the future flash
storyline on legends of tomorrow Barry
Allen from the distant future leaves
this secret message for the legends or
really it's for rip hunter in the
legends just hear it that implies that
something really terrible is going to be
happening to him which probably has
something to do with the sava thar
plotline they did tease that Barry would
be learning things about his future
which just you know sounds like Martin
Stein is going to confront Barry with
some of this information and we know
that Supergirl is gonna be coming back
for another crossover on the flash in
the second half of the season it's just
gonna be like a Supergirl flash episode
so it won't it won't be like arrow or
legends or anything like that so I'm
wondering if they're gonna tease how
that might happen to each of the shows
this season has done like a slightly
better job of threading plot lines along
so that when they get paid off it's a
much bigger deal because they've been
seeding it the whole time so be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's a
new round to the DC giveaway that's
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video what's gonna happen next is
I'll post spider-man homecoming and then
there was like a Kevin Feige super post
where he basically like went on and on
about you know Marvel vs. DC the state
of the comic book filmmaking industry
and why it is that they'll probably not
be able to make a deal with Fox for the
x-men characters so those will be the
next videos to post spider-man will
probably be next just because it was a
really cool spot
and stuff so again I it's gonna be
really fun and Happy Thanksgiving
everybody that celebrates Thanksgiving
this week well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my killer
frost video from last night and you can
click here for my god speed versus
avatar video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you